[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti e grazie di essere
qui oggi sono stata invitata su questo
prestigioso palco per parlare di
connessioni e io lo farò in un modo un
po particolare
un modo decisamente scomodo perché vi
parlerò della possibilità di restare
connessi anche nel dolore e chi mai ha
voglia di parlare di dolore nessuno
perché solo a nominarlo il dolore ci fa
chiudere ci spaventa ci allontana ma io
oggi sono qui a raccontarvi la mia
storia come donna e come psicoterapeuta
in cui ho scoperto che proprio dentro il
dolore c'è un seme non importa grande o
piccolo qualunque tipo di dolore una
crisi esistenziale una separazione un
lutto una grave malattia
dentro ogni dolore c'è il seme della
nostra trasformazione e se perdiamo quel
seme rischiamo di perdere la fioritura
della parte migliore di noi e io invece
credo che oggi più che mai ci sia
bisogno di entrare in contatto con le
nostre parti vulnerabili sensibili
quelle in cui ci sono le nostre risorse
altrimenti sopite ed imparare a
maneggiare il dolore come fosse creta
per trasformarlo per me tutto inizia qui
con questo gioco quello di unire i
puntini da piccola lo facevo tutte le
settimane mi divertivo e ogni volta mi
stupivo che i puntini davvero si
unissero con un senso creando un disegno
molto bello pieno di armonia e mentre
giocavo stavo imparando ad avere fiducia
nel processo mentre si fa anche quando
non ne vedi la direzione e il senso e
avere fiducia che i puntini si uniscano
prendo a prestito delle parole di steve
jobs ci permette di seguire il nostro
cuore anche quando la vita ci porta su
strade davvero difficili e questo fa una
grande differenza è nella mia vita
questa differenza l'ha fatta
io ero una bambina estremamente
sensibile per molte persone ero troppo
emotiva le cose che divertivano gli
altri bambini
per me erano fonte di stress e di
sopraffazione rifuggiva i giochi
competitivi violenti le grandi compagnie
preferivo stare a giocare per conto mio
con poche persone leggere disegnare ogni
esperienza dentro di me aveva un impatto
estremo e mi esauriva energeticamente
per esempio non riuscivo a studiare con
i miei compagni o anche solo a leggere
se in una stanza c'era una tv o una
radio accesa perché il mio cervello
processava tutto contemporaneamente ma
gli altri ci riuscivano allo stesso
tempo però avevo un empatia naturale e
capivo gli stati d'animo delle persone
anticipavo i loro bisogni e avevo un
lessico e motivo preciso già da bambina
mi ci sono voluti anni di studio e di
pratica per scoprire che si tratta di
una caratteristica neuropsicologica
naturale che si chiama alta sensibilità
o ipersensibilità ma ahimè allora ero
soltanto una bambina strana diversa mi
sentivo aliena spesso è la maggior parte
delle volte incompresa
quindi ho dovuto fare una scelta molto
precocemente per essere accettata e
comprensibile
dovevo tagliare fuori la mia sensibilità
ma quando facciamo questo genere di
scelte
creiamo una vera e propria frattura
nella nostra identità e di solito il
corpo che poi si fa carico di esprimere
questa sofferenza e infatti il mio corpo
parlava e come la mia dermatite da
piccolina parlava del mio estremo
bisogno di contatto fisico di carezze di
abbracci di sostegno emotivo le mie
emicranie alle scuole medie raccontavano
della mia fatica a stare in un modus
operandi operazionale troppo rigido che
tagliava fuori la mia creatività il mio
pensiero divergente
ma la mia compagna di giochi da bambina
era la sma l'asma da piccola è
un'esperienza estrema vi assicuro ma
anch'essa mi ha insegnato qualcosa che
mi sarebbe tornato utile più avanti e
cioè a fare attenzione ad ogni singolo
respiro troppo corto
mi avrebbe fatto sentire soffocare
troppo lungo avrebbe forse generato una
crisi ridere di pancia avrebbe forse
provocato un broncospasmo e correre
giocare sudare
va beh vi ricordate non correre che sudi
era il rimprovero più bizzarro e usato
dai nostri genitori anni 70 80 ma per me
era un filo più problematico nonostante
la mia sensibilità fisica ed emotiva
cresco curiosa aperta al mondo
desiderosa di trovare sempre un senso
profondo nelle cose e di ritrovare quel
senso di connessione persa dentro di me
e col mondo quindi appena posso comincia
a sperimentare cose anche un po
particolari per i tempi
comincio a sperimentare tecniche psico
corporee
a vent'anni pratico meditazione sotto la
guida di alcuni monaci zen
poi mi iscrivo a psicologia sperando di
trovare lì
molte delle risposte mi laureo in
psicologia mi specializzo in
psicoterapia prendo diversi master un
perfezionamento e finalmente arrivò nel
mondo degli adulti mondo che o
estremamente idealizzato e in cui mi
aspetto di trovare una grande
connessione e armonia ma mi accorgo che
non è propriamente così a dispetto
dell'iper connettività che oggi ci
permette di videochiamare ci da un lato
all'altro del globo di fare altre
meravigliose cose
le statistiche ci parlano di un maggior
senso di isolamento sociale e di
solitudine
nell'epoca storica in cui la medicina è
più avanzata e tecnologica
abbiamo un sempre maggiore ricorso ad
ansiolitici psicofarmaci in genere e
antidolorifici
no questo non è il mondo che mi
aspettavo questo è un mondo che non
sente anzi direi che è un mondo che non
vuole sentire che fa di tutto per non
fermarsi e ascoltarsi profondamente e mi
sono anche resa conto che nel giro di un
centinaio di anni sono cambiati quasi
tutti i tabù se prima erano il corpo la
sessualità alla nudità un certo tipo di
linguaggio certe idee fuori dalla norma
oggi quali sono davvero le cose di cui
abbiamo paura a parlare di cui abbiamo
timore anche solo al pensiero
beh dalla mia esperienza sono
esattamente la solitudine l'isolamento
il vuoto il dolore fisico
la malattia quella grave la morte e la
malattia mentale perdere il controllo
sulla nostra mente e mi pare anche che
oggi la strategia più attuale più usata
è più rinforzata socialmente per
affrontare queste sofferenze che
dopotutto fanno parte dell'esistenza
umana sia una sola scappare
scappiamo dal dolore come si fa a
scappare del dolore in tanti modi
anestetizzando il corpo per esempio con
il cibo
una bella abbuffata ci darà una botta di
serotonina e di endorfine e poi arriverà
il senso di colpa a punirci oppure con
l'alcol
una bella sbronza perché no un paio
d'ore di leggerezza e poi i nostri
problemi
ci aspettano al varco oppure possiamo
anestetizzarci attraverso la sessualità
cambiando continuamente partner in modo
da sentirsi potenti ma poi quel vuoto
nel petto ci ricorda la nostra verità o
ancora possiamo scappare dal dolore
anestetizzando la mente riempiendoci di
così tante attività anche piacevoli è
sport viaggi hobby tutto pur di non
fermarci e ascoltarci profondamente
o ancora possiamo scappare dal dolore
diventando dipendenti dal lavoro o
dipendenti dai social o da quelle
maratone tv che anestetizzano il nostro
cervello per ore a volte per giorni
un ultimo modo di scappare dal dolore è
anestetizzando le emozioni si chiama
alex city mia non so cosa sento non
sento niente o chiamo tutto con lo
stesso nome noia no queste strategie non
mi convincono e non sono adeguate ad
affrontare le sofferenze che fanno parte
della vita umana
ci deve essere un altra strada che non
sia scappare dal dolore o annegarci
dentro quando ti fai delle domande in
genere la vita poi ti porta le
esperienze per trovare le risposte
avevo appena compiuto 30 anni ero
autonoma facevo il lavoro che amavo la
psicoterapeuta aiutavo le persone nella
loro evoluzione
scrivevo in una prestigiosa rivista di
psicologia mi ero potuta permettere la
mia prima casa e la stavo arredando
quella mattina quando squilla il
telefono è la mia dottoressa ciao
dottoressa come mai mi chiami dimmi ciao
nicoletta hai un minuto ti posso parlare
sì certo ma ti sento raffreddata stai
bene
sì ho il raffreddore ma questo guarisce
come scusa nicoletta hanno trovato delle
cellule tumorali trovati un oncologo il
prima possibile
guarda non riesco a dirti altro ci
sentiamo vi assicuro che la telefonata è
andata realmente così mi si apre la
terra sotto i piedi mi tremano le gambe
respira nichi respira
non ho fatto nulla non sono corsa da
nessuna parte non ho telefonato a
nessuno mi sono messa semplicemente
gambe incrociate seduta sopra il mio
nuovo tavolo a guardar fuori dalla mia
nuova finestra l'arco delle montagne il
monte rosa innevato il cielo azzurro il
sole quel giorno e sono stata così credo
un'ora e mezza due non sapevo bene cosa
stavo facendo stavo semplicemente
ascoltando la mia voce interna che
diceva non fare nulla
resta ferma non andare in pezzi
resta intera continua a respirare non
scappare dal dolore continua a sentire e
io ho continuato a sentire e ho pianto e
ho tremato e ho rivisto la mia vita fino
a lì è quello che avrei voluto ancora
fare ho immaginato questa cosa che
cresceva dentro di me senza ancora
sapere realmente l'entità ma continuavo
a stare lì ea guardare fuori e succedeva
qualcosa di straordinario più guardavo
lo spazio del cielo più si creava anche
una sorta di spaziosità dentro di me e
questa bomba deflagrava in un modo
differente come più comodamente e quella
comodità gliela stavo dando io non
reagendo non scappando ho capito dopo
quello che stavo facendo
stavo semplicemente mettendo in campo
quello che avevo imparato nella mia vita
fino a lì e cioè a stare anche quando le
cose fanno male poi sono scesa da quel
tavolo è per sei mesi ho fatto tutto
quello che c'era da fare visite esami
invasivi due interventi chirurgici e
alla fine ce l'ho fatta con una buona
dose di fortuna in sostegno dei miei
cari
ho sconfitto il cancro ma mi sono resa
conto che in quei sei mesi sono stata io
stessa vittima del tabù che il dolore
non si dice o non si dice troppo perché
altrimenti le persone si spaventano o si
preoccupano e poi si allontanano e ti
lasciano ancora sola e quindi sì mi sono
fatta aiutare in quei sei mesi ma la
cosa più straordinaria è che non ho mai
smesso di lavorare con i miei pazienti e
naturalmente i miei pazienti non
sapevano nulla della mia malattia in
corso come era giusto che fosse ma lo
spazio del mio studio era l'unico luogo
in cui il dolore era dicibile in cui la
sofferenza poteva circolare e potevamo
rimanere sensibili alle nostre ferite
io silenziosamente l'altro parlandone e
lì mi sono ricordata di chiron è
l'archetipo del guaritore ferito che nel
mito aiuta gli altri a guarire ma
essendo stato ferito a sua volta e non
potendo guarire dal suo male aveva
dovuto imparare ad andare così in
profondità nella propria sofferenza e
questo proprio questo lo aveva reso
abile ad accompagnare gli altri alle
mire le loro ferite senza perdersi in
quei sei mesi sono diventata una donna
migliore è una terapeuta migliore perché
ho imparato la compassione che è
l'empatia nel dolore e non è più il mio
dolore il tuo dolore ma il dolore
dell'essere umano
ho imparato che il dolore messo in
circolo attiva risorse profonde nelle
persone ho imparato a riamare e
reintegrare la mia sensibilità ma mi ci
sono voluti ben dieci anni per rompere
il mio tabù e poter parlare
pubblicamente del cancro senza sentirmi
una donna più debole o patetica o
pesante o una psicoterapeuta meno abile
chissà perché poi
e allora ho cominciato a parlare
nei miei articoli nei miei siti nei miei
libri nelle riviste con cui collaboro
e qui oggi con voi e ho ricevuto
centinaia di messaggi da sconosciuti che
mi ringraziavano proprio per essere
immessa a nudo in quel punto per me così
doloroso e vulnerabile e allora sì oggi
sono qui a fare un lavoro scomodo a
parlare di dolore ma per lanciare dei
messaggi differenti di speranza e di
fiducia perché la mia esperienza è stata
differente e può esserlo quella di tutti
noi
ho imparato che davvero possiamo avere
fiducia nel processo anche quando ci
sembra assurdo anche quando non ne
vediamo assolutamente il senso ho
imparato che il dolore come l'amore come
la gioia va messo in circolo non teniamo
ce l'ho dentro parliamone
perché solo così libera compassione
condivisione e una sorta di gratitudine
nella compartecipazione
e questi sono antidoti potentissimi
contro il male fisico il male psichico e
la sofferenza in generale e l'ho trovata
a modo mio la terza via per affrontare
il dolore che fa parte dell'esistenza
umana e che non è scappare o annegarci
dentro ma è che il dolore va
attraversato come un ponte
e mentre tu attraverso il dolore il
dolore attraversa te e ti trasforma e
dall'altra parte del ponte ci sei ancora
tu ribaltato come un calzino ok ma tu la
versione migliore di te la 4.0 la 5.0 to
intero testa cuore pancia e solo quando
siamo interi e connessi possiamo essere
davvero felici e possiamo creare
connessioni felici con il mondo intorno
a noi
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]